repeat yes welcome back I'm glad to be
here so
last time you came in you told me such
incredibly interesting stories
I'd love to hear more if you have more
to tell oh yeah I mean there's a
lifetime lifetime of storage detail yeah
the rumor is you've got all kinds of
great stories
well that's because they had a lot of
great adventures and uh
some of them were actually death defying
you know and
the other ones were uh I mean when like
clockwork you know
there's a saying that uh no great plan
ever survives reverse gunshot
after the first shot is fired everything
is chaos then it's you know adjusting uh
improvised so yeah that's life adjusting
improvise even in the middle of a
situation
so yeah I've
been there and done that really
a variety of things that other people
haven't done it's like Dante's Inferno
you know nine rings of hell
I've seen them been there you know
not trying to go again because uh once
just once there's enough and there was a
tough acts to follow
so um
I'll go to uh
uh event that took place in my in my
existence
and um
you know it was
now that I look back on it you know I
was I guess I was out of my rabbit ass
mind you know
and somewhat cool for Cocoa Puffs even
you know
not even know that it wasn't supposed to
be possible it was it wasn't supposed to
be done
but uh
I made it through and
this was the event that took place
uh Figueroa and I I call it figure hard
because it's supposedly the longest
straight Street in the world where it
was at one time no telling now
because it runs from
uh Exposition without a turn all the way
to Long Beach and that's like 26 months
I mean uh all the way to San Pedro
that's like 26 miles of highway so
that's a lot a lot of money but I think
they can't figure out because of all the
girls that are working 26 miles
from uh from Jefferson all the way down
it's long and straight Street all the
way down to yeah about a dozen girls
from there yeah wow
oh
I had a pulled up
in the car with uh
a person at that time was my significant
other
and uh when we pulled up
you know I was going into the store to
purchase a few things and actually you
know I was actually what she wanted
and a guy pushed up on me had the door
open
and the guy pushed up on me
and he said say man give me a quarter
and I was just I didn't like the way he
acts you know because it was more of a
demand it was like aggressive
and so you know I looked at him and told
them well I don't have a quarter I lied
but it was a reaction I don't have a
quarter he said
you know use the n-word you're a
[ __ ] line you got a quarter I
looked at him I was like man you
disrespected my family here he said [ __ ]
your family
and my natural reaction well when you
know when when the talk is over
so the conversation was over and I fired
on them he went back and I I was angry
at this time because he would you know
it's more like not that he disrespect
her he disrespected me I mean you know
of course he disrespected but it was
more he did in my presence it made me
look like you know um Willie fufour
Sammy sausage and I wasn't going for it
so uh I engaged them and I drove them
back because he didn't expect in that
first one when I hit him you know kind
of had him spinning so we went back
about four or five houses and she jumped
out the coin she was screaming for me to
stop
and I pushed him back so far until we
ran into a car and he turned and he ran
at this time I disengaged you know I was
figured he learned his lesson I turned
around I was walking back I was still
angry and she was still hollering I
wasn't really paying attention to her
suddenly it came in you know she said
look out behind you and I turned around
and he was swinging the pickaxe
that's the the one that the miners use
you know to dig both hands are pointing
and I think it's eight pound eight pound
head
and uh 28 inches from tip to tip and
both tips are pointed and it was already
in motion and I watched it
I watched it in slow motion I'll
actually go through the air Arch and hit
me in the chest
it hit me in the top part of my picture
it came out under my arm because it's
curved and it stuck me in the left arm
and I'm looking at it and when he hit me
you can hear the Boom
and they said you know I was looking up
and I was down on my knees I was down on
one knee and I looked down at the
pickaxe through me and I seen the shape
of the pickaxe pucker through the skin
and I was like man I'm dead
gotta be I thought it came out my back
you know I went straight through the
heart and everything else like cop
dragon or somebody
but it stuck me in the arm and I was
paralyzed and I looked up at him and I
tried to stand up and he pulled it out
when he pulled it out
you know blood came with a lot of it
like a
a bucket of blood came out this would
look like you mean
so I made it up to my feet and now I was
trying to disengage because I was
getting the shitty into the stick
and he swung aside hit me again
[ __ ] he swung it sideways I
couldn't utilize my left arm but it was
paralyzed from the strike and so I
turned my body and I took the ax handle
on the arm but the pick is so long
that it went around and went in my back
punctured my lung and I felt it it's
like a balloon pop and I couldn't
breathe you know and all the air just
so uh at this time I moved back and he
went for the third shot he went for a
head shot at this time Dr Jekyll left
and Mr Hyde showed up
and Mr Hyde showed up and said my ass a
whole bunch of times when Dr Jekyll
can't do it Mr I can
so uh I was able to the adrenaline surge
I broke the paradise and I reached up
and I caught the pickaxe where he was
swinging it hit me in palm of the hand
and I moved it to the side and I fired
on him
so he went back several steps and I hit
him again now he was dizzy because I was
giving all that guy even though I didn't
have a lot left
so we dropped a pickaxe and I pushed him
back to a worth Iron Gate and I took his
shirt and I hung it over the gate
and he was stuck like a Marinette trying
to get down
and I bagged up and I was looking and my
tennis shoes were making a sponge sound
they were squishing because it had so
much blood in them and I bagged her but
I stepped on the pickaxe and I looked
down and I saw it now it's my turn
so I reached down picked it up and I
took two giant Leaf toward them and I
spent a I was gonna stake them out but
she was hiring no please don't please
don't and I stopped at this time I was
crying because I was so angry and I
turned it around and that's an awkward
way to hold it but I hit him 63 times
I worked him off the gate you know so
many times he's shirt tore and he came
off the gate
and he was crawling and talking about
hell well somebody called the police I
said [ __ ] you didn't call the
policeman you just hit me now it's my
turn
so I just beat him across the street
while he was crawling and I beat him
till he couldn't move he was down and I
was just
I couldn't move my arms no more that's
the only reason I stopped because my
arms felt like lead
so I threw the pickaxe down I turned I
was walking back to her and she came up
said you got bubbles coming out your
back I said my lung is punctured another
dude came out the house with some towels
he put one on my back
and put one on my chest
so as we went to the car I said uh
give me the keys
he said you can't drive you're gonna
pass I said give me the keys man so she
gave me the keys when we got you the car
I thought about it I said you know what
I'm second thought you better
gave me the keys because she might be
right
so anyway
she said I'm taking you to the hospital
I said no you're not I said take me to
my mom's house
no I'm thinking I said take I know what
I'm doing take me to my mom's house
so we headed for the Crenshaw district
and she's speeding and running red
lights I said man slow down before you
killed not just me yourself as well so
slow down she said you just passed it I
said no I didn't I heard everything you
said she asked me what did I say and I
repeated verbatim so she slowed down
somewhere report about said okay
I get my Alias name this is my new name
this is how we're gonna do this
we was over at the mall the shopping
center some blues mess with the car I
came up and one of them just hit me with
a pickaxe
that's the story we're gonna feed the
police and everybody else when they get
there
so she got the car she ran to my mom's
house to call the M&Ms and I decided I'm
gonna get out and go in the house as I
was walking I seen them gigantic bloody
I wear size 15. so again I say gigantic
bloody Footprints and I was like I'm not
gonna walk in my mom's house and you
know leave her with the cleanup
so I sat down in the hallway where I sat
on her door
my mom came out crying no no not again
you know not my son don't take this with
you pleading with God because she
figured if I was on death bed
so I told my niece who was you know
maintaining my mom take her back inside
you know so she got her off inside
my girl came back out and said she said
they're on the way so I fed her the
story again I said you got it okay good
when they came when Eminem's came
uh they asked me what had happened you
know I found him a line and they cut my
shirt off I said and he busted he bust
my lung you see how you know I said
because I couldn't breathe and I still
had difficulty breathing
so he cut his shirt off and looked at
the back in nice size hole I said it
also hit me in the arm and put them up
with left arm up and there it was
gigantic hole
so um
you know that was the last thing I
remember until
I woke up
and I looked at my girl she's standing
at the foot of the bed I said how long
I've been here she said about four days
I said
that's why I'm hungry in the
[ __ ]
get something to eat and she was like oh
well
they got some food in the vending
machine and and Tower number two I said
well you got a big ass cold don't walk
your ass over y'all I wasn't really
making sense it just came out of it
see y'all right now but can I touch you
before I leave let's text me I said why
you asked me that she said because the
last time I touched you you said [ __ ]
get your hands off of me
I said give me morphine
because at the military experience where
each time they shot me out they shot me
up I engaged I engaged the corner I
engaged the doctor and everybody else
who was around
so I knew what they was giving me
because I I lived through this before it
had to be when I act that way it has to
be that particular drug
so she went out and asked a nurse the
nurse said yes she's paying you he goes
like this this is the reason why he was
going off on everybody
so uh they told me it was going to
change the medication but it still had
to wear off
uh she came back in and uh
told me what had happened
told me
how they had stitched up some left the
other ones open because they didn't they
want to hear from inside out I mean I've
been through that a lot of time where
the wound is so severe they wanted to
heal from the inside
instead of closing up with my faster
inside and become infected
so um
yeah when I say I got able to pickaxe
yeah I got hit with it
anyway
all right repeat well thank you so much
for coming in again yeah man I
appreciate it I uh I appreciate it I'm
delighted to hear that you might be
getting out of here yeah the thing is
in 31 years I didn't have an opportunity
or a chance to
hear what I've been through and it does
something when you hear it for yourself
when you hear where you've been and what
you've done
and you know it's true because you did
it it makes a difference I didn't talk
to the psychiatrist the psychoanalyst
nobody in there they said that anger
problem I knew that
I knew that still know it
but I didn't talk to nobody
I didn't talk to nobody about it because
unless I do gotta act like a man you not
because a man can talk about it
that's what I was able to do now and I
appreciate you giving me informed an
opportunity now you're talking about 100
000 people or more fantastic
because uh it gives them an opportunity
to understand
what's going on
excellent
thank you so much you're welcome
thank you